1991 the world's first website was torch
in the coming years one turned into
hundreds and hundreds into thousands
ultimately crowding the internet
necessity does the mother of invention
so this was the time to structure and
make the information on the Internet is
accessible which led to the birth of
search engines search engines help
people to find information on the
internet so now the question arises how
are search engines able to identify the
information people are searching for
this happens with the help of Search
terms users enter to search for the
information search engines identify the
web content containing those phrases
thereby displaying it into the search
engine result pages also known as serps
so to break users or search engine
traffic to your website you will need to
optimize your web content with the
Search terms or relevant keyword which
users are actually looking for say if
you have a shoe website then it should
have keywords like Snickers sport shoes
and some phrases like best knickers for
men which will help you to gain more use
attraction and for this search engine
optimization plays an important role so
the process of getting good quality and
quantity of traffic on your website or a
web page through search engines is
called search engine optimization or SEO
in short search engine optimization
practices involves on-page SEO of page
SEO and Technical SEO each of these is
directly or indirectly responsible for
getting organic traffic to your website
with the growth of SEO industry and
Rising demand for SEO experts leading
companies like Microsoft udemy Deloitte
and Siemens are already hiring SEO
expert with salaries going as high as
100 000 dollars per annum that's as you
wrap in two minutes if you like this
video hit the like button and subscribe
to Simply learn to get more information
about SEO
[Music]